we're going to be talking about Kuku
Khan today also known as nemour the
Submariner known in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so the questions are who is he
what does he represent why is he so
dangerous
[Music]
so Prince no more he's also known as the
Submariner and he was first published in
Marvel Comics in 1939 you probably
remember when that got released huh yeah
I mean I was just being born at that
time so I was three
actually never heard of this guy though
all right so let me tell you a little
bit about him so he's a mutant right
because his father is human but his
mother is Atlantean from the city of
Atlantis his name means avenging's son
so he's the prince of Atlantis which is
underwater Kingdom but he's more of an
anti-villain and that's because all the
movements that he makes all the war that
he's raging on the world or I guess the
the land is because of his perceived
like transgressions that you know people
have done against him and his people so
it's not just other heroes or villains
it's also like the military and that
kind of stuff his superpowers are super
speed like flying and swimming he can
breathe both in the water and in the air
he has super strength and long life like
this guy is centuries years old
now some of these details changed when
more became a live action character in
2022 in Black Panther wakanda forever so
he's still a mutant right but his mother
is an indigenous woman from Yucatan
Mexico right Yucatan but his father is
unknown right but no more is considered
the firstborn son of Jacques
and that's because he was born
underwater he's like the first person
out of their people group to be born
underwater so let me give you a history
about that so the entire Village of
Yucatan was infected with smallpox so
through a shaman their God Jacques which
is the god of rain and abundance he
comes and he reveals to them a flower
that's grown underwater and it's infused
with vibranium this flower this herb
that they ingest it cures them but it
turns their skin blue and you see in the
corner of that Warrior so that's how
they looked but they couldn't breathe
air anymore so they went into the water
and then they build the city of dalocan
which instead of Atlantis it's like a
talocon in the film so he's he's not
like that though so did he exactly so
his mother drank the herb while she was
still pregnant and he was born
underwater but he looks different than
anyone else as you see his skin is in
blue he has pointy ears and wings on his
feet and he can breathe there and he
could breathe air that's right the
people of talukan cannot so you see that
like mask on her face yeah that has
water in it exactly so that's how they
can come out of water now the people of
telecon worship no more they call them
right which is actually a real like
Mesoamerican deity right so Alex you
grew up in Mexico you're Mexican yes did
did they ever talk about kukukan in like
the education system or like in your
upbringing at all was that was that
brought up oh yeah I mean you studied
that in elementary school yeah you told
I mean they teach you the whole story
about
a history of all those civilizations in
Mexico you know like the Aztecs the
Mayan Tolteca uh as the
um
you know there are different ones the
one part of the north of Mexico close to
the United States is a mapache
yeah okay so uh you you know you you
they taught you all the stuff and what
does that mean the God of this
destruction god of the rain or the deity
of the mankind you know all the stuff
Yucatan is a real place right yeah yeah
have you been there before uh no but I'm
from Chiapas I'm like so
that's the capital so you could have
drove a couple hours and got there well
it's not a couple hours it's like it's
not to scale yeah it's not got flowers
like top 12 13 hours uh it's really nice
Tennessee to New York yeah yeah it's
right there it's like 12 hours uh Merida
is very known that city has said they
want the cleanest city of the whole
Mexico so
Yucatan is the state right and very
interesting the
I just want to show you guys the
difference of you know the Mexico City
right there and chicken
is the city where these uh cuckoo can
they made you know he's a God and you
know all stuff but these guys the Mayans
they create up uh a temple
and it's called cuckoo can also the
temple the temple is called just to
honor the God right the cuckoo can but
this is the one of the pictures cuckoo
can means uh and the Mayans language is
a snake quetzal okay so quetzal is I
don't know if you guys heard bereza as a
bird
it's a bird so it's a serpent
would bird-like qualities yeah Bird yeah
yeah you know what's kind of interesting
about the snake is when God
um came down and talked with Adam and
Eve and and you know he put enmity
between the snake and that's that means
they're they're supposed to be enemies
and it's really interesting how many
different cultures embrace the snake
yeah but it's a snake with feathers hmm
so that's quetzal I don't know you guys
saw this beautiful bird is kicksaw ah so
it's green with feathers well it looks
like 11 flies that's cool yeah so if you
go to Guatemala they use that as an
official birth I like his hair yeah I
wonder if this is kind of trying to pay
homage to what the serpent used to be
because the fact that God cursed the
serpent that you'll crawl on your belly
it's often like known in Christianity
that the serpent used to fly or had
wings in the garden was this beautiful
snake that's what I'm thinking like even
in like Asian cultures you see the the
dragon but it's really just a long
snake-like thing that flies around right
it's not like a dinosaur you know when
you think of a dragon you kind of think
of that dinosaur looking thing blowing
fire but it's just like a serpent so
uh anytime I look at this stuff I'm
always thinking man you know the Bible
literally said that the drag or the yeah
the dragon who is the serpent will
deceive the whole world and you look
around all these cultures or worshiping
serpents and Dragons including
you know new agers who are in America
who want the the snake to go up there to
their Crown chakra like that's part of
the whole Kundalini yoga stuff
meditation is uh inviting that serpent
up to up through your chakras
that's an alarming if you're a Christian
and you know who the serpent is but all
the serpent and you see when you go
through those parliaments and you see
this you know lots of different you know
monuments and you can see that it's a
serpent with feathers and all the stuff
and uh it's very interesting that uh
these God Coco can it's kind of like the
main god for them they who create you
know the main kind and stuff like that
it's kind of like the Romans uh in
Jupiter right all the you know the
Greeks Zeals Zeus okay Zeus and even one
more piece like back in um um Israelite
days uh the god Bale was the one that
was like the the provider he sent the
rain he made the plants grow that's what
they taught
yeah so it's just a counterfeit of God
God does all those things for us and
then these guys are just usurping that
but it's kind of interesting that these
Gods it's not just like oh this the god
of the sky no these guys those three
gods the Coco Cannon and Zeus and
Jupiter is the god of the Heavenly
Kingdom really that he create mankind
you know so he's the Creator so check
this out so this guy cougar can has
these abilities okay walk on water
control the fire
and also control the wind
okay wind water fire so check this out
so it's in Spanish but it's a cool cool
can right so coke is a feather and the
other one is can as Serpent
and nowadays they want to the more
um professional guys that want to
translate the whole coats of Mayans and
everything they said they
the the real translation is cool cool
Kansas three words is worship the
infinity God
whoa okay wow
yeah like you know infinito you know
like and like Always Forever it's crazy
to think about
you know he Satan was the one that said
I will I will be like the most high and
all these things but we're just we're
told that he can transform himself as an
angel of Light he's described
prophetically as a serpent a snake but
it's like he Embraces that he could be a
beautiful angel that people worship but
he's like no I'm the serpent I'm the the
infinite serpent God let me tell you
they want worship
see and whoever worshiped the Beast
right everything's about worship so
nowadays those professionals guys they
want to break the code of Mayans and all
stuff they say you know that's the
perfect word the word is worship
Infinity god wow uh I just want to show
you one once again about these pyramids
right uh the city is uh but the temple
is
and those that the whole city of Mayans
the civilization started like in the
after Christ the 750 to 1400 okay that
is very interesting that
all the stairs
there are four of them right yeah you
know how many steps they have
a lot 91 each and I'm sure it's like
another one or something like that so it
says 365 steps
one for every day yeah the calendar
right when I put a picture is the only
two times during the year
I don't know exactly that day or during
that month you know like in a Sprint or
in fall
something happening in the Sun and how
that pyramid is built and how the Sun is
going in the sunset
you see the Shadows over here and you
see that it's a heads of like a serpent
or whatever so when the sun is going
down
little by little
you can have you can see the shape of
the serpent coming down yeah but if you
watch the time lapse it'd be like
yeah it's really I mean talk about those
guys like how they knew I mean they
didn't have where to put it how to build
yeah so when when the shadow comes down
when the Sun goes down it goes it's
moving and the end of The Shadow thing
the sun it goes to the the head of this
serpent I just want to give you guys uh
some facts about the Mayans uh
astronomical skills were so Advanced
that they could even predict solar
eclipse and they were so so
sophisticated that they have an
observery extractor remain even today I
mean right there you can see it so
they're very into about stars and you
know astrology
and I don't know if he's astronomy but
maybe both they were like very into
about they didn't predicted uh Eclipse
uh it's very interesting in even NASA
they have their own it looks kind of
like the same right wow and I just want
to give you guys
um remember I show you the map right
it's right here the Yucatan what is the
demayans right but Mexico City was the
Aztecs right so let me tell you the
Aztecs also has the same God with the
serpent with feathers and it's called
quetzalcoat
that's the guy so it looks like the
Dragon and also
um uh he used to fly you know in between
the skies and everything I mean that was
there and he had the same sort of powers
of like control over the water wind and
uh I don't know exactly if it was
control the wind and everything but
supposedly you know he has you know he
flies and he's the Creator and he's the
creator of mankind get some caught and
uh it's very interesting quetzal caught
so I just want to share that with you
what's interesting you're talking about
NASA Observatory and it's the same you
know they even have a lot of terminology
like Apollo you know you read the Bible
Apollos is some Greek god and stuff so
you look at the the names of their
flight missions and space shuttles and
stuff and they all have like these
mythological names so I mean I just
think that's interesting isn't it
interesting they also this guide is
green and remember when you were when
we're doing the the replacement guts uh
the Greeks I know they're you Egypt they
had those Greeks
definitely associated with Egyptian yeah
Egyptian is green like kind of like the
Batman and the I think Osiris is green
but yeah yeah
it was Green you were talking earlier
about all these different cultures
having these types of similarities
yeah it's like you know all they're
doing is counterfeiting you know one
piece of Truth and then they're coming
up with their own versions of it and
it's like it's like every every bit of
God's creation was meant to worship Him
and even creating Lucifer in heaven he's
meant to worship God but he takes that
and he says no I want people to worship
me now and then he has all these little
mini versions of him so like God wants
us to be like his character the devil's
got his gods in all these different
cultures and they're all you know
basically boiling back to worshiping
Lucifer but well you know we we have an
advantage because we have the Bible we
have the whole
understanding of who wins and who loses
in the end but can you blame people who
you know Lucifer he's a big powerful
angel that can give you all the kingdoms
of the world if you didn't know the
truth why wouldn't you worship him he
told Jesus bow down I give you
everything he has the power to do that
can you imagine a god like that like wow
this is him so I mean it's really a
major deception that's why it says that
he's going to deceive the whole world
uh yeah it's just man that'd be hard
that'd be tough to deal with I mean can
you imagine I mean I don't know I mean
maybe really Satan I mean really
show those guys like I'm the God of this
and he was flying around on me who knows
I mean I mean you see I mean you read
all those
you know manuscripts you know like hey
this guy used to have control about the
wind the fire and all this stuff but
it's mystical so I don't know I don't
know if it's real or not you know but
right but in the Bible the serpent was
cursed right this animal that was cursed
as a result of deceiving mankind Adam
and Eve and so it represents like lies
and Temptation and evil being overtaken
or possession being overtaken by the
devil but in gnosticism of course we see
the complete opposite so narcissism is
like this collection of philosophies and
to distill it down very very simply of
course there's so many interest
intricacies about it but it it views
that each one of us has like a God
within or like our gods and also this
this mentality of Lucifer is the one who
brought knowledge who brought Liberation
and freedom to humanity so in gnosticism
the the serpent is depicted as the aura
Boris right and that represents Unity of
all things this eternal cycle of
Destruction and Recreation so it's sort
of like the the The
Eternity of the soul and so you guys
know Helena blavatsky you know she is
than occultist issues like the founder
of luciferianism She Wrote books about
it and all of that so she Associates the
serpent or serpent worship with wisdom
which we know is the complete opposite
who does wisdom come from right God God
but that's what was offered at the
Garden of Eden was wisdom and a snake
did it so it's like they're just
counterfeiting that and even just the
thought of okay this is a a illustration
or image of their God I'm so glad that
our God is not promising like life and
death continually someday we'll be done
with this thing I don't see the Hope in
that at all but you know it's so Twisted
when we look at the story of of Adam and
Eve and you have this serpent or the
conversation between Eve and The Serpent
and him promising this Enlightenment
right once Eve eats the fruit
Satan disappears like the coward that he
is he runs off and who's left it's God
who cleans up the mess so I don't really
understand well anyway they're painting
another picture I should say Satan is
trying to have himself reimagined as
something So Glorious and really he's a
coward who runs away we're kind of
discussing what you just said about like
did they really see these beings like I
don't think that somebody was just
sitting around like hey would be a fun
mystical God you know they probably did
see it and you think about like if we
wrote on Cave walls what we believe is
truth in the Bible Eve talking to the
serpent she really saw the serpent it
was real she really was communicating
with Satan and then a manifested way and
I believe these people are doing the
same thing they're they're seeing the
same thing so when we see on the walls
like this giant person with a dog head I
don't doubt they really were seeing
stuff like that yeah the thing is like
any Christian who watches these types of
movies they're continuously seeing a
mispertrail of God right and also a Miss
betrayal of Satan as well so you have
the villain who's all that the person
who's coming to destroy the Earth or to
get rid of evil is always who the
villain right and the superheroes well
they're trying to save Humanity but
they're also perpetuating evil who we
know as Satan so it's just this complete
flip each and every time and in
Christianity so the one who's coming to
cleanse the Earth is God and it's
something that brings us hope it's
something that we're looking forward to
I feel like if someone continues to
indulge in these Hollywood messages on a
subconscious level like their allegiance
begins to shift because your ID the idea
keeps it's like cognitive dissonance
it's like two different ideas coming
together and it's creating confusion to
put it into perspective with somebody
that can understand like let's just say
hypothetically
um a Satan worshiper probably is not
going to come into the Christianity into
the church and listen to a sermon and
probably not have Bible studies with you
at Great length but we do that with with
the devil's world and it's like tons of
Christians go and engage in all this
like worship of other gods basically
through the superhero stuff but you
don't see the reverse of that no yeah in
that time of the civilization I mean the
Bible doesn't say that but uh it was a
Christian there like or somebody stand
up for truth
you know like I would talk about Joseph
you know in the middle of
civilization like worship Gods over here
whatever I mean God use you know Joseph
will say you know why you need to stand
out what is truth you know what are the
Ten Commandments you know I'm not gonna
be sent against to my God Allah
to me I would be so cool to find out
like okay and those civilizations like
you know this side of the world like
somebody stand up and say like hey you
know what that's evil we don't worship
that I mean that'd be cool
probably because even when you look at
what was happening in Africa back in the
day well it's often told of all the
spiritualism that was happening there or
how you know some Caribbean islands who
practice Voodoo it's coming from those
territories in Africa but there was also
the Ethiopians there that were Sabbath
Keepers they believed in God and so yeah
they may have been a small region out of
the entire continent but they were there
and it's also like Hush Hush in history
and in teaching for a myriad of reasons
so I wouldn't be surprised if it was the
same in in South America yeah
well Central South America like because
yeah all right I have to get that right
uh Mikey can you read this verse for us
yeah First Corinthians 10 31 says
whether therefore ye eat or drink or
whatsoever you do do it all to the glory
of God right and I feel like this is a
form of protection because of what Luke
16 13 says you can't serve two masters
so when you make a decision as to who
you who you're going to follow your
actions should match that therefore
everything that you do should be
glorifying God it's just a form of like
putting a hedge of protection around
yourself I also think it's kind of like
just letting you know that whatever you
engage in in life like have have a focus
or a thought of God in your mind you
know what I mean keep that perspective
so if you play if you eat it's not like
separate things like I go to church on
this one day but all week long it
doesn't matter and do what I want it's
like always have the perspective of God
right there in everything that you
choose to do it's so amazing to see how
one thing often leads to the next the
next the next and then you're in a place
where you never thought you'd be so a
lot of these superheroes they're
involved in Magic they represent magic
they draw their powers from magical
things
fans of the Atlantis story took it upon
themselves to create
an Atlantean magic book of spells now
whether someone is practicing these
spells and and they believe it's real or
not it's still giving Satan an open door
that has real consequences that's where
we see something we know is a sin we
know it's Abomination and we're like oh
it's just fiction but yet if you were
married you wouldn't be writing this
fiction book about oh when I committed
adultery on my wife it just felt so good
and isn't this great honey you know oh
yeah it's fiction you know we would not
we just don't justify other fictional
things but yet when it comes to sorcery
and all these things we're like not real
exactly
you guys know what the tactic of the
talukan army was in Black Panther
wakanda forever
I watched the LED yeah I would hope so
yeah it says about the music they were
singing kind of like a hypnotized or
their enemies or something exactly so
the Warriors would come up out of the
water and they're singing would
Hypnotize The Enemy which led them to
drown themselves wow so this oh actually
we have a whole video about this I break
it down I'll put it in the cards above
this video also in the description below
you can check it out short synopsis of
of what was happening with the telecon
army versus you know their enemies
but these telecon Warriors
they have a similar tactic as the
hypnotic Sirens have you heard it I was
just about to ask if you heard of those
yeah yeah so what do you know about them
well they like the Pirates would be in
the on their ships and they would hear
this beautiful music in the distance and
they would it was like hypnotic and
they'd go after it and these they were
beautiful women from what I understand
that would seduce them and then just
like devour them and stuff yeah and then
lead them into crashing onto the rock
yeah yeah that's right we'll see that's
two different ones so that's more Greek
and then what you're talking about is
Roman so in the Greek they were depicted
as like birds with human heads for the
Romans they were either beautiful women
or mermaids yeah but I mean both goals
are the same they're searching men off
of their purpose right and then they are
leading them to their destruction using
music to see which is wild to me like so
morbid deceiving people through music
and we know that I mean this is yes it's
it's mythology but there is some
realness to it and that music affects
our brains it affects our our mood it
affects our actions and all these things
whether it's at a small level or
completely you're hypnotized and you're
taking over it's affecting you it's not
something that you can take control of
it's on a molecular level yeah it's
almost like um you know telling a joke
there has to be an element of truth to
it otherwise it's not as funny if
there's no you know somewhat truth to it
and and in all these stories that
they're telling
um you know some of the Productions that
have been the biggest like popular
popular projects they're very kind of
teetering on this line of what's really
going on there's a war in the universe
and all that you know what I mean
there's always these elements of what's
actually going on and I think it's just
it's more deceptive the closer it gets
to the truth that's right sure and we
often say that these movies are like
Satan's Playbook right Hollywood is
Satan's Playbook he's hiding in plain
sight and the goal of the telecon
Warriors of gnosticism and really of
mythical creatures that we find in Greek
and Roman philosophy they all align with
the goal of Satan which is what Scotty
John 10 10 the thief cometh not but for
for to steal and to kill and to destroy
and I have come that they might have
life and that they might have it more
abundantly and that's the hope that we
have although Satan's there trying doing
everything he can like no days off type
motivation to steal and to kill and to
destroy us we have God who is working
doubly harder to come that we may have
life and we may have it all abundantly
we have to make a choice right which
will we choose and then
more of just making the choice what will
our actions show about who we're
actually choosing yeah yeah so it's kind
of interesting back then it was those
kind of gods right God of days God of
that but now in 2023
what kind of gods the people just going
nuts
for them to worship the American Idols I
mean we talk about music right people
who are now the new Idols yeah
I mean acting and you're so famous and
people go crazy you know and and it's
kind of interesting we still have those
gods and we still worship not just
people though stuff too I mean people
complain about how prices are going up
inflation this inflation that but
they'll put themselves in debt to get
that car or to get those shoes or what
have you the stuff that America drink
every morning man that thing is going up
man or even appetite you know there's
certain things even in grocery stores
prices are going up but people just
can't let go of certain things yeah
anyway yeah we should be a little bit
more Broad in our scope like it's not
just well you know I don't worship this
person but you know what in your life we
should now analyze what in your life is
taking the seed of God in your heart
that's really the choices here you know
it's interesting
um when you go to see movies and and you
know generally it costs 20 bucks right
you go to the movies you buy some
popcorn you do all this right do you if
you spend you know a lot of time and
money going to watch these movies you're
so supporting that how many people that
do that actually go to church and put 20
bucks in the offering plate just saying
you know what I mean giving your
attention and your money is also an act
of worship wow powerful right there and
it's accountability too when you talk
about morality all the things that are
coming up about what's happening in
Hollywood the abuses
it keeps your mind fixed on them and I
think that's really why God in the Old
Testament he told him not even to speak
of those Gods why because he didn't want
them focusing on that he was just like
hey you know think of me and think of
pure things and stuff don't even look
the practices what they do they worship
their gods that's what he said don't
even look them how they worship that's
right well as we said earlier the choice
is really for each of us to make and
making the choice for God is a big step
and he doesn't leave you alone he has
the support that's found in his word he
has the community that's built around in
the fellowship of Believers also we have
our little you know little tiny
community of little light studios in the
corner of YouTube here Henry thank you
so much for watching and supporting and
we pray that this was a blessing to you
and uh hopefully that if it was a
blessing to you it'll also be a blessing
to others if you decide to share it to
people all around what you got going on
Alex you have a Spanish t-shirt you're
wearing yeah that's right so thanks so
much for your support uh become a
patreon uh and you're gonna be having a
really nice really nice teacher and Gobi
said to our lightwear that shop and you
will find another awesome teachers there
to support Ministry what you got going
on Mikey Yeah we actually started little
light kids we're producing children's
content now so we could really use your
support over there by clicking like on
all the videos subscribing so we can
grow that channel so the more people can
find out about it so that kids will
actually have good positive things to
watch
and Scotty we've been traveling around
quite a bit how can people like get in
contact with us to maybe book a speaking
appointment or anything like so on
little lightstudios.tv there's a little
tab at the top that says booking and um
yeah this year we've been quite busy in
fact this last weekend was really cool
we were four of us were in four
different places at once all preaching
in different churches and and that to me
was just neat you know we're out in the
field as well we don't just make videos
so if you're interested in having us
come and speak to your youth group about
some of these media topics or you know
current events or something like that
um go check it out at
littleightstudios.tv look at the booking
tab at the top and uh we'd love to come
share with you that's right and we'll
see you guys next week on LED live
bye-bye
do you have questions about the Bible
that you've been struggling to find the
answers for video Bible study or VBS for
short is a YouTube channel that answers
your Bible questions in five minutes or
less check out these easy to understand
comprehensive videos talking about
everything from what happens when you
die to why does God allow suffering make
it your goal to deepen your relationship
with Christ this year and subscribe to
video bible study on YouTube to help you
along your journey
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to show
kindness to the world
every day is an opportunity to do
something that lets someone know your
think ing of them
every day is an opportunity to give
without expecting anything in return
I don't know
every day is an opportunity to notice
someone in need and to go out of your
way to help them
every day is an opportunity
to do one small thing
to show someone you care
to make the world a better place
if you're looking for good wholesome
educational content for your children
subscribe to our new channel little
light kids
[Music]
thank you